shut it down it's ariana grande
sweetheart day you guys raise your hand
if you're bumping that Newari joint
today our weekends and our lives just
got a little sweeter with Ariana's
fourth studio album and I got to know
right now what do you guys think of it
so far and does it stack up to dangerous
woman or my everything
now listen among the 15 tracks is a song
dedicated to her fiance Pete Davidson
called wait for it Pete Davidson
it's basically
[Music]
do you guys hear the lyrics or see ya
they confirm that yet the fiance's of
two months are definitely soul mates
Arianna told Jimmy Fallon last night she
wrote the song and said it to Pete and
I'm quoting her here a week after we
started hanging out and stuff
I was made and I sent it to him and I
didn't know what to call it so I called
it Pete gonna be that or like this is
about Pete Davidson
like I said poetry Ari also opened up to
her pal Fallon about her fiance and wish
she knew he was the one I had the
biggest crush in the whole world on him
the whole time like forever I'm not a
crushed person I don't have like crushes
on people I don't know I'm not crunchy
but um I left and I like joking when he
said to my tour manager I was like I'm
like I'm marrying him 100% like I'm like
I like I'm literally marrying him
Oh apparently Pete felt the same way
he told GQ even though they haven't
started wedding planning he's sure she's
the one quote the day I met her I was
like hey I'll marry you tomorrow I sent
her a picture of engagement ring she was
like those are my favorite ones and I
was like sick so sick marriage man he's
so aloof but you know what so is Ari
they're goofy but they're in love and we
love love but sweeter is also filled
with so many other gems including the
album's final track The Ballad get well
soon pays tribute to the victims of the
Manchester bombing last year in its
lyrics but also the songs length re
added 40 seconds of silence at the end
of the track to get it to five minutes
in 22 seconds aka five 22 which is also
the date of the bombing beautiful right
well up next for Ari is Mondays MTV VMAs
where she'll be performing God as a
woman are you guys you ready for some
more new jams it is new music Friday and
I've been waiting for this song all week
fresh off one of my favorite songs of
the summer one kiss with dual Aoife
Calvin Harris recruited Sam Smith for
his latest piece of magic called
promises
[Music]
but
[Music]
[Music]
but
I'm filling that one you guys fill in
that one I love it all right can be like
a bit also drop this thing over own and
if you dug Havana I think you'll be into
the set sultry and sexy real friends
Patrice Whaley
[Music]
[Music]
real friends
[Music]
it goes without saying but Camila has
been doing her thing and well since she
stepped away from fifth harmony and when
I chatted with the mastermind behind her
career Simon Cowell
he said she always had it in her yeah I
mean look like we did with the girl
yourselves we never told them what we
think they should do they kind of made
their own decisions
Camila always had it in her to know
where she wants to be and I she's really
doing well shining bright okay and
finally if you don't know the knocks
well then get on it the EDM duo have
produced a vault for the ages I'm being
extra but Method Man is on it and the
song slaps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I dare you not to bop around to that one
I love Fridays I love new music new
music Fridays
alright guys on Monday we'll have a
special preview of the MTV Video Music
Awards and look back at some of the VMAs
shadiest moments of the year so make
sure you come back but before I sign off
yesterday we lost another music legend
the Queen of Soul and if you guys only
knew how many times I've fallen down in
Aretha Franklin rather Hall on YouTube
literally just last night cut to the
close real quick look at these bags I
was staying up listening to Aretha not
to mention I've got her 30 greatest hits
on vinyl she really is one of the
greatest voices of all time and I think
Jack Black said it best when she starts
singing she blows people's minds
everybody wants to party with Aretha